Brad Pitt is reportedly being  investigated after allegedly getting  physically and verbally abusive with one  of his kids with Angelina Jolie the news  comes just days after Angelina filed for  divorce citing irreconcilable  differences the actress is also seeking  physical custody of their six children  according to People magazine the LA  County Department of Children and Family  Services is investigating Brad for an  incident that allegedly took place on a  private plane apparently someone  anonymously reported the altercation and  alleges the 52 year old actor was  drinking at the time their source adds  pit is denying abuse allegations the LA  County Department of Children and Family  Services tells ET they are never allowed  to comment on matters involving minors  et has reached out to Jolie and Pitt  scamp's for comment